showing a lot of perseverance and
resilience and whatever else to kind of
get back to you know I think this week
is rankings 38 or something like that so
you know to be playing like Top Class
tennis obviously not at the level that
maybe he was used to for you know best
part of like 10 12 years I think
um you know and I know firsthand the
struggles that he's gone through over
the last few years but I think
um you know physically he looks he looks
good right he's been playing
um you know pretty much a full schedule
for the last year and uh you know
hopefully he can kind of keep bringing
back his his his tennis level and uh you
know keep moving up the rankings